live
hello everyone hey guys and Merry
Christmas Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas
did you what did you get for her did you
get anything uh yeah
sauna portable sauna thing you're really
weird
oh that's good I got some gym gym rings
I don't know I got a lot of liquor yeah
we got that idea that I drink
anyways uh let's get on with the
extinction segment and uh the other day
we were talking about a little bit about
genetics okay and uh let me show you
something that I picked up this week
okay and it's all these muscle girls and
uh they're all women a couple of them
had problems because they were kicked
out of soccer
uh they were accused of having too much
testosterone okay so these are the
testosterone gals you could say
and uh it's not that I chose black girls
it's us when you put Sports these are
the girls you get but they're they're
white women especially uh in wrestling
and so on uh kickboxing so you'll find
uh there's a mixture there but yeah the
question is uh
are women uh more masculine like our men
less masculine you know it's one of the
issues going around today
uh whatever your opinion is about that
whatever the statistics say about that
and I'm saying that that together with
uh homosexuality uh the fact that people
have
um uh so many kids today that have
autism and so on I'm saying all that's
traceable to one thing and here's the
graph that I guess synthesizes it all
okay for the last hundred thousand years
we've been inbreeding okay and at some
point I say that's got to produce
problems part of the problem is we lose
our genetic diversity and because of
that you know we start having these
genetic problems these genetic you can
call them diseases or or you know
whatever we want to call them
um okay so what's the issue of fellow
answers he says
um
says uh this year is illogical because I
said we've been inbreeding for ever
since you know 200 300 000 years huh
yeah go ahead yeah
yeah this theory is a logical that's
that's what I'm saying no a person read
the red one which is what I say no so
we've been breeding ever since we
haven't had any input of new genes from
monkeys or Elephants or fruit flies
okay and the other person says this
theory is illogical all species inbreed
by this argument because different
species cannot interbreed that's got a
point yeah without external genetic
manipulation genetic diversity increases
with time as random mutations accumulate
and those which don't prevent the
species from surviving will persist
sources of declining genetic diversity
Arc Extinction levels extinction level
events that create a genetic bottleneck
like a crash or something yeah of that
sort and conflict between rival groups
where one group massacres the other
which is documented throughout human
history
yeah so uh let me just synthesize what
this fellow said because I think it's
what a lot of people maybe even the
majority of people out there including
geneticists believe and that is that uh
genetic uh genetic diversity increases
over time I say it's exactly exactly the
opposite a species can only lose genetic
diversity throughout its history when it
finally loses most of its genetic
diversity that's approximately when it
goes out in a background Extinction and
this is a graph that I have in my book
The Neanderthal book for those of you
who are familiar with it uh I'm saying
that over time you can only lose genetic
diversity because you have no other
choice but to inbreed okay in other
words you're you're marrying your own
kind and if you know what happens uh if
brother and sister Mary especially
through several Generations like in the
case of the Amish where they've been
in bringing for the last 350 years they
started out with a population of a few
thousand and today there are 350 000
like a thousand times uh am I saying
that right yeah 100 times more
and several Generations 350 years later
and now they're having genetic problems
and I say that's what happens to the
human race as a whole but we've been
inbreeding for a lot longer 200 maybe
300 000 years since our species you
could say began and here we are you know
with all the problems that we find today
that's my take on that so
um yeah I disagree with this gentleman
and also with
um most of geneticists out there who
believe that uh genetic diversity
increases because you have all these
variations accumulating I'm saying it's
not only because of these crashes that
this fellow talked about but the fact
that we inbreed cannot help
um you know diversify our genes that's
my that's my point okay okay uh so one
fellow says
I don't deny that mutational load and
decreasing genetic diversity potentially
plays some role however the onset of all
of this correlated perfectly with a
massive increase in toxic exposures in
which we can include into induce similar
behaviors and animal models on top of
that you have media altered parenting
Styles c-e-g parentification and
emotional incest emotional instance
whereby the parents subtly or
deliberately forces the child
repetitively into something to serve and
suit them in many cases the role of the
opposite sex specification single
mothers in particular will often destroy
their male children and try to prevent
them from separating sprinkle in some
misandry okay so essentially what this
fell is saying that uh this is uh he
said he gives a little credit to a
nature but he says a lot of this has to
do with nurture in other words with uh
how we're educated
environment and maybe yeah he's
referring to the same thing the fact
that uh genetic diversity the fact that
the human race today has almost no
genetic diversity a lot of people are
not aware of that but yeah we have
almost no genetic diversity and again
I'm saying that's because we've in been
inbreeding for so many thousands of
years now some of that you could say
lately especially that's where the
confusion comes in how much of that is
related to food and environment how much
of that is due to education and the way
we're you know liking this spell says
you know father and mother maybe don't
give the proper
um uh you know um
image of what a man should be what a
woman should be isn't it then easier to
look at other animals
and they don't have so much uh social
sophistication it isn't as complex right
right well uh we do have at least two
cases that I can talk to you about as
far as that is concerned one is the
Lions one is the Sheep
okay and if you look at the Lions
there's very few of them in the in the
world we went to from about 150 000 that
there were 50 years ago today there's
only 35
000 almost a fifth of the Lions we had
uh just 50 years ago and what happens is
you know you can imagine a shrinking
population and what they end up doing is
intermarrying within themselves
and add to that the fact that these
lines you know they were not made by God
yesterday you know they've been evolving
for six million years at least so
they've already whittled all their
genetic diversity now we have the last
few who are intermarrying you know
inbreeding within themselves within
their groups and you know I think that
has an effect at some point that's one
animal the other one is the Sheep the
Sheep
um have been uh
statistically shown to have almost 10
percent homosexuality uh within their
populations and
um and so what you can draw from that is
that you know again sheep are numerous
unlike the lies they're numerous we we
breed them on purpose but you know we
kind of inbreed them on purpose also
because we want the best sheep the one
that has the most wool and the bigger
ones and whatever and we do that with
cows we do that with you know like uh
bulls and so on we do that with horses
especially race horses there's a lot of
inbreeding a lot of selective inbreeding
and we are the mother nature here we're
the ones doing the the experiments and
I'm saying what we're doing is
um in doing this favor to the animals to
those species because what we're doing
is we have all these sheep and I think
part of that process is that we're
forcing them to inbreed uh probably
unknowingly you know a lot of these
animals are
um artificially inseminated okay and
that means that they pass the
milk around
uh so that's not a good deal uh but
that's what we do and that's what we
have so we do have homosexuality among
lions and we do have homosexuality among
sheep and
um you know the homosexual Lobby takes
it in One Direction I take it in another
Direction I'm saying that that's got to
do with inbreeding okay then let me
spend this one last time one last one
yeah what about if you take uh assuming
it is new a new species such as an
insect type
or their homosexual insects
well again we would have to go through a
full list I think uh homosexuality at
least is uh reserved mainly as far as I
know for the mammals maybe the birds uh
perhaps the fish I don't know about
insects insects I haven't heard of one
but I wouldn't put it put it past but if
they're the new species then
because it's a good way of telling which
one is a new species or not once your
genetic diversity if a species whatever
species you want an insects bird you
know whatever you want look out there
for if you find that they have very
little genetic diversity I'm saying
that's an old species it's already
whittled it's uh genetics I guess I
guess pool what I'm asking is we'd have
to find a case for a species that has a
lot of genetic diversity but
homosexuality to see if that can be a
case because then it would it would
debunk well uh we have the case we have
one case at least uh one experiment is
not the only one there's a couple more
uh parallel to this okay with different
kinds of animals this is one the most
famous Calhoun's uh mice experiment and
what he did he put a bunch of mice in a
I think it was nine uh cubic meters or
cubic feet of space and he put uh four
pairs of uh four couples right and at
the beginning it was uh great because
you know it was
um uh Eden for the mice because they had
all this space they had all the food
they wanted no predators no diseases so
they were isolated they had all the food
and water they wanted so they were
really in in glory they were in a
perfect Island you know and what
happened was they started to reproduce
and a few months later you know they
ended up with 2 000 plus mice all
descended from the same four pairs and
the issue here is that you could say
well it's environmental because you know
there was a lot of overcrowding as you
can see there a little bit okay and uh
what happened uh the mice eventually
um some of them became gay okay they had
a gay mice so he you could say he
created uh homosexuality in the lab and
that's one issue a lot of them became
autistic uh the with John Calhoun who
was a psychologist said uh or the way he
classified that he says they stopped
being mice
these in other words they were no longer
what you consider a mouse you know when
that goes out there and finds these
things and knows what to do out there in
in the world now these were completely
different kind of animals I guess they
don't have to I guess it's like the kids
nowadays yeah yeah they don't have to
know how to survive so they stop being
human so it is he said he said that was
a microcosm of what's happened to
humanity a lot of psychologists objected
to his findings but the point here is
that uh you know we cannot isolate
genetics because in this case they all
descended from the same grandfathers the
same uh you know uh well no we had it we
had the theory of how to isolate
genetics if he made the enclosure ever
bigger proportional to however many rats
there that's our experiment then it
would be a genetic tell the people then
it would be strictly genetic because
then there's no
yeah volume cap yeah right right right
right but then uh you know the question
is whether you're reproducing his
experiment in the sense that his was
specifically designed to test overcrowd
right and in this case you would open a
valve and allow you know the pressure to
I mean that'd be hard because at some
point you have like billions of rats
big [ __ ] place okay so here we have
another father says if oh go ahead read
it I wonder if we could continue for
longer than you think if we began
introducing new genes through genetic
viral technology that sounds kind of
cool not say this is good or bad it just
might be a possibility yeah the question
is whether uh so we inject uh we have a
vaccine right and we inject it in you
and we say okay now you're a little
different people maybe that's not the
coping vaccines were they change your uh
genetic code in some way okay let's go
with uh uh thought experiment on that
okay so the question is uh one of the
two we probably don't end up being human
at some point because we got to change
ourselves quite a bit in order to not be
inbreeding and say well now we're not
inbreeding because that guy is very
similar to me but he he he's not exactly
like me because his genetic makeup is a
little different okay fine that's the
first issue is that a different species
the other issue is whether if if you're
not the same species you might have the
same problem that cats have big cats
like lions and tigers they can create
ligers and tigons but those animals
normally I think they only had one case
where the guy could reproduce but then
again I think that only went for one
generation that's where it stopped in
other words they become infertile okay
and so yeah we might create another
human but the question or this
human-like he's no longer like us
whatever comes out of there right
because his genetic code is different
but then because they're different maybe
when they get together with one of us
who knows what comes out of that you're
saying Mother Nature doesn't like
cheating she doesn't like cheating
I feel you to die after a certain time
it doesn't matter what you try to do
you're scheduled to die please don't
avoid it she put blocks everywhere it's
like if I try to avoid my dad I mean I'm
70 years old and maybe I got 10 more
years to go at most you know so so the
issue is can I avoid my death well I
doubt it very much I mean even if we put
all those blocks she's got the freaking
Sun clock that's going to explode at
some point like even if you guys put all
the Vlogs she put all these friends she
doesn't play fair does she you're not
gonna beat her
okay uh attending a little bit the
subject uh this is Biden he says looking
back at 2022 I feel more confident about
America than ever what is he talking
about he says my economic plan is making
the United States a Powerhouse for what
for Innovation and especially
manufacturing once again
isn't it already a Powerhouse of
innovation
in in innovation no problem my problem
is with this word manufacturing where is
he coming uh with this thing I mean I
thought the age of manufacturing was
over never to go back there again like
we won't go back to agriculture like we
won't go to Hunter back to Hunter
Gathering I mean if if uh Biden tomorrow
said oh we're going to be the number one
country in the world with
hunter-gatherers uh I don't think so
that'd be pretty badass though yeah yeah
I'm back to Hunter Gathering I don't
think so but that's more or less what he
said when he says we're going back to
manufacturing so let me put in the
proper context here okay Hazel said
let's go back to Cole yeah well Germany
yeah
Germany has cold but no one okay so this
is this is uh let me put in the right
context here it is okay we have here uh
five of the largest companies in Taiwan
and the largest obviously is tsmc Taiwan
semiconductor and
um they're an international company and
they are the ones that sell chips to the
world uh they're big they're one of the
top sellers of chips manufacturers and
sellers of chips and uh there you see
some of the numbers that they have and
what's the issue uh among among other uh
things that they sell they sell chips
for the car industry so they have a lot
of uh demand for their product okay but
what is the problem it's in Taipei it's
in Taiwan in fact I used to work with
tsmc as well when I worked at AMD okay
we talked with their folk and then it
was an Army okay because we
subcontracted to them okay so what's the
issue well you have China that one's
Taiwan
imagine if China tomorrow were to attack
Taiwan okay and one of the two conquer
it and get a hold of tsmc or destroy it
or maybe the Taiwanese destroy it before
the Chinese get it or something along
those lines well certainly you have all
this uh
Supply that disappears from from the
planet okay or is controlled by the
Chinese together with the technology
meaning the machines and everything to
manufacture them that's a big step for
China you know suddenly they would be
like eight years ahead from where they
are now uh in the manufacturing of tips
which you could say and we're not
talking to her about potato chips these
are real chips you know these are things
that run the world okay so imagine China
gets a hold of that and that's part of
China now and they control it from not
Taipei but from Beijing okay so this is
the issue so uh what has Biden done at
least
in his administration here's the first
one that he did and this is the pasta
chips Act okay again chips and not
potato chips okay and who's involved in
this Intel Corporation
and Intel is going to invest a few
billion and the government passed an act
where they're gonna subsidize help Intel
uh create ships here in the United
States and what's there in the United
States
and so you can see there uh what they
say supporters including companies like
Intel right say the bill is necessary to
compete with other countries that
subsidize their semiconductor industry
referring specifically to China right
but uh some who voted against they said
it viewed it they viewed it as corporate
welfare I mean does the government give
you billion dollars when you start your
business why would they give it to these
guys well because they're too big to
fail and they claim that they're
competing
um against companies against countries
that subsidize their Industries okay but
the issue is uh they're going to build
this plant they're building it already
by the way uh in Ohio okay and they're
going to be Manufacturing in the United
States just in case for two reasons
there's a security is a national
security issue which is if China gets a
hold of Taiwan that's one issue and the
other issue is you know just in case
something happens over there
uh we want to be able to uh uh supplier
Supply Supply the market with the chips
that the United States manufactures
aside from giving jobs to Americans etc
etc and the subsidy has to do a lot with
the salaries because the people in the
United States would demand higher
salaries than in Taiwan and that's part
of the problem okay so that's why they
need the subsidies that's one issue but
the other one here in this Biden went to
visit what was it in November he went to
visit Arizona okay it says uh Biden
tout's uh Advanced chips manufacturing
and visit to Arizona semiconductor plan
turns out that
um
not only the chips act allows for this
but uh this is a plant that's being made
or or founded by tsmc itself and they're
going to be building chips in Arizona as
well also giving jobs to people and
again a question that's related to
National Security the fact that you know
that if someone takes over Taiwan
meaning the Chinese that might create a
problem for the chip distribution in the
world and here you have the United
States saying we're looking ahead that
maybe in one or two years China will
attack Taiwan just in case we're going
to have our chip plants somewhere else
okay and tsmc would be owner of one of
them they can always expropriate that
from the Chinese if it's in Arizona and
the other one in Ohio okay so they're
creating jobs they're creating
manufacturing jobs will this overcome
overrule uh you know flood out the
service economy my answer is no services
will continue to grow at a faster Pace
than manufacturing and if this is his
idea that manufacturing is coming back
I'm saying that's only politics blah
blah blah yeah they're creating
manufacturing jobs but it's not going to
change the trend that trend is in the
direction of service might give it a
little a little bump and then I'll just
go right back yeah yeah I mean uh how
many Industries the United States wants
to have it wants to bring back
everything it had uh before China grew
and took over a lot of the manufacturing
because of its cheap labor
I don't think it can do that because a
lot of uh countries out there will buy
from China not from the United States
because it will be the same product but
cheaper well that's a good question
maybe the US should start thinking about
cheaper labor well it can that's Market
it's run by the market that's one issue
but the other issue is that the United
States is doing this for the National
Security issues which doesn't concern
any other country you know it concerns
the United States but you know countries
in Africa and uh in fact in Europe and
South America they're going to buy
wherever it's cheaper on the market and
if it's cheaper in China made it the
same way they won't care that's I think
the bottom line
okay uh and parallel to that similar to
that related to that we have the fact
that the Senate passed a 1.7 trillion
that's trillion with a t not b not
billion with a B okay truly in spending
Bill okay so they authorized 1.7
trillion spending Bill the other day uh
that's the Senate it still has to go to
the House of Representatives but what's
the issue the issue is that
um you know we have inflation
that's one issue and it is using the
word trillion yeah and the other one is
yeah but it's not a pocket change and
then the Australians
the other one is debt I mean all that's
that that you're seeing there so the
government is incurring debt and
creating money and that's why we have
inflation and on top of that you know
you have now to cover a bigger budget
yeah anyway I know there's a budget
keeps increasing year after year after
year and they can't stop it
and uh one of the problems there is that
the same thing is happening to every
country in the world right now every
single country there's not one you can
select and say that's not happening in
my country no way it's happening in
every country
and what's worse about that is that all
those countries are pegged to the dollar
so if the dollar Falls these countries
their money falls even further
and that Crea that means that they have
higher debt higher unemployment than the
United States they're all clinging from
the United States and so here's the big
Empire you know run from Rome I'm sorry
not Rome was it Rome no it's called
Washington DC and everybody's clinging
from there and cleaning from the dollar
and so just you know think about that
the fact that the macroeconomics doesn't
look very good for the world okay we
have inflation all around and what we
were saying a couple weeks ago that
they're expecting a recession in 2023 so
we're going to have a a great year this
year 2023 okay think about that
okay final issue oh no I think it's not
the one it's oh yeah kind of like the
final issue here we have uh Will Smith
okay and fellow says I remember having
watched one strange Rock a documentary
somewhere where Will Smith at some point
defined and he defines life more or less
he doesn't remember exactly I couldn't
find the exact definition I looked at
the video that he talked about but I
couldn't find the exact definition and
but he says something like along the
lines of this he says matter that
reorganize itself in a in a way such
that it slows down the decreasing in
entropy in the universe
that's the definition of Life entropy by
the way is amount of disorder so it
decreases the amount of disorder so
that's his definition of life or that's
the one that at least this fellas
proposing or that's the one he thinks he
heard
okay so uh first thing I do is
um tell you what I think I mean off the
bat what I would say is just entropy
defined as less disorder or anything
that that we use the word disorder as an
opinion
I could think something's especially
that's the first one uh true that is
true but uh again defining
um life uh something that decreases
disorder I mean what are we talking
about with the Lions uh they decrease
this order we're talking about bacteria
they decreases poetic yeah I don't know
what that really means it
encompasses too much I mean there's too
much room for interpretation right yeah
uh so what do I do I Define it in a
different way slightly different way and
here it is alive or living a natural
object it's got to be natural not
something we made or that a beaver made
like a house or whatever uh that moves
against the path of least resistance I
used to say it's moves against the
gravity but my son here corrected me or
as he always does
and uh no allowance for you this month
okay
um but essentially it's uh something
that moves Against Gravity if you can
move against gravity it's because you're
not a rock
okay that's that's essentially it and
we're not talking about you throwing the
rock rock upwards it's got to do it by
itself and it's got to be a natural
object okay and that's essentially what
uh it's a definition that covers all
life in the universe I think it's uh
broad it's it's a perfect scientific
revolution definition and I don't think
you could have anything against it I
don't think you can find an exception
okay uh essentially a living being has
the ability to move against gravity and
life is a group of vaping entities and
living beings again it's got to be a
natural object okay so but I took issue
with a couple other things that uh we're
mentioned in that video okay here's the
first one uh you can go ahead and read
it if you want somewhere around 4
billion years ago life emerged on Earth
the type of life that's there depends on
what food is available the first
creatures on Earth were microbes it's a
law of nature that life evolves to fit
its surroundings it turns out that the
big question for life is what are we
having for dinner food is energy
everything living needs it okay that uh
that's what uh Will Smith said in that
uh documentary and so I'm saying hold it
these people
were talking because this was uh run by
uh I think the History Channel a big uh
one of those TV shows that's important
out there I can't remember which one but
uh they say that life is that which must
eat etc etc they talk about food you
must eat uh what are we having for
dinner tonight and when you say look uh
the reason we're all going to die is
because there's going to be no food and
people say where did you come up with
that
and here these people are telling you
life is food essentially and he goes
through this whole rigmarole where he
says um that plants receive their food
from the sun he talks about food a lot
and it's like what's Extinction the lack
of food and it's like and never clicked
in anybody's mind that it's like a food
how did the dinosaurs die oh it was an
asteroid you're basically it's like out
of nowhere I mean how about the food you
know nobody thought about food it's kind
of like life is food and death is not
food kind of like that okay that's one
issue and here's the second issue okay
let me read that one in the future when
all human life is gone bacteria will
still be there
it doesn't matter what a planet is made
of or how poisonous its atmosphere
simple microbes will work out a way to
get it
is there life out there somewhere as we
gaze up on those stars there will be
nothing remotely like us looking back
during three billion years ago life
didn't even have a brain
okay the question is who was it who
doesn't have a brain I think we're
talking about someone else here maybe
it's the people who do these analysis
and
um I can only give you my five cents
worth on that I'm saying if there are
aliens out there with human level
intelligence
they look exactly like us more or less
there's no green uh martians out there
there are no silicon based entities
running around with intelligence out
there none of that all that is Hollywood
nonsense okay and here let me tell you
why I'll synthesize it okay and we'll
end with this and here's a synthesis of
what I'm talking about okay
and what we have here is um
uh specifications to create life
necessary for Life uh the Sun the Earth
for example or any plant we're talking
about really any Planet here okay can't
be too far away from its star or too
close to it okay because life uh would
not be able to develop in such a uh
system uh we have maybe issues that are
less important as distance from the sun
such as you know the magnetic field the
tilt of the planet okay whether it's on
the ecliptic of the of that star okay
the sun size the planet size I mean as
the planet uh too small even if it's at
the right distance maybe it's just a
little Pebble uh I don't think that'll
work and if it's a giant one like
Jupiter well maybe it won't work there
there either how about the sun size or
the star size right uh maybe it's too
big maybe it's too small without having
a bearing on whether life develops and
so on and so forth uh so those are some
of the uh things that I've brainstormed
as far as uh what the habitable zone is
for life and so that's those are the
first constraints okay so you have these
constraints first on where that planet
is located how big it is how far away it
is how cold or how hot it is what kind
of um
um atmosphere it has does it have enough
carbon to create life and again I'm not
going to go into that but no silicon
life no green life and and green humans
and I mean you know plants yeah but not
animals that are green that's what I'm
saying okay and uh so so you have a
certain constraints first from the
system from the cosmic level then you
have uh within the planet
um how did how did Intelligence develop
this guy says uh intelligence or a brain
did not develop until I don't know much
later and I'm saying as soon as life
developed it had intelligence
let me say that again the first entity
that had
um that that moved Against Gravity which
is life already had intelligence it had
a brain it's called a central processing
unit in order because the first one was
the cell and the cell has to have a
compartmentalized uh system where each
one is dedicated to some function
that's known as a brain okay so life and
brain are synonyms every living entity
has a brain okay in one way or another
because a cell has a brain and uh until
you define really what a brain is or
intelligence which no one has to this
day we can't even talk about those
subjects so that's where we should
really start
okay let's move on to
um what we have today phases you say
what are you going to talk about the
phases of the moon uh no we had a
problem the other day because I
presented the following okay let's start
at the beginning uh I said and this just
a synthesis I said that we have the
universal movie okay Universal movie
means that every frame that you're
staring at there is uh just locations
just distance from one object to another
there's no motion whatsoever in each one
of those frames okay I can put a solid
anything uh you want there I can put a
table for example and that's a solid we
call it a solid I don't need to have the
table moving for it to be a solid same
with liquid I don't need to have liquid
running down a hill I can have uh just a
a puddle of milk on the floor and call
it liquid
I can say liquid point and say liquid it
didn't move but I it's I can label it as
liquid and the same goes for gas gas
does not need to move I can take a
snapshot of a astronaut releasing gas in
in space I take a snap they're called
encoded hopefully and I take a snapshot
of that I've got gas here I call it a
gas could be smoke could be anything I
showed some examples the other day you
can't do that with plasma because plasma
is defined as a process of ionization
you need to have two frames of the film
at least of the universal film in order
to see before and after okay meaning in
the case of quantum mechanics that the
atom is whole and in the next frame it
loses an electron we call that
ionization something happened to the
atom that happened is called plasma
plasma is not the end result the
snapshot that you take after it lost its
electron or gained an electron that's
not plasma plasma is a constant process
where some atoms are you haven't even
lost anything but they're part of the
soup called plasma some lose some gain
some are neutral and you have this
entire soup all together
you take a snapshot of that you don't
have plasma because plasma is the
process of ionization and I don't know
how why is it important if you call
plasma a state a phase okay it seems
like stamp collecting uh it is an innate
because then they've discovered so many
other one guy said 18 different types
and I mentioned a few the other day uh
of states of matter and the question is
can you compare a plasma against a solid
is that a fair comparison are we
comparing boy running against boy
that's the issue okay so
and that creates problems because
when when
we have a single frame in a universal
movie we can point and say this is the
object that I'm going to be using to do
this or that in my theory so I I
identified the object first so I say
that's a table
okay table it's not moving it's in one
frame of the film then in the movie I
have the table jumping up and down
throwing it over a mountain whatever I
want
I can't do that with plasma I can't show
you plasma to start out with and say
that's plasma and I'm going to do
something with plasma which is what
these people do especially the electric
universes you can't do that because it's
already moving plasma is a concept not
an object it's not a thing it's a thing
in motions and it's the in motion that's
important you're equating it to fire
exactly and that's in fact one guy said
that uh said that plasma is just fire
okay so um so here we have a situation
one file says uh go ahead and read if
you want so I am imagining an analogy
for when you say single frame of the
universal movie
I were to compare the universal movie to
a rope and cut a very thin slice it
would still be a measurable thickness
and I could cut it thinner
but I don't think it would be possible
to ever conclude you have a single frame
of a continuous object now wouldn't that
analogy also be true for time you can't
cut thinner slices but never truly a
single frame
even a camera has an exposure time
so what's the issue the issue is this
fall doesn't understand uh what the
universal movie is what the concept of
the universal movie is or what it's used
for this is what he's saying he's saying
look if I take a continuous object such
as a rope or any elongated object he
says he stretches it across three frames
of the universal move he says you know I
can't put a continuous object or an
elongated object in one frame because it
stretches all the way to all these other
frames
and again he's not understanding what
the universal movie is saying yes
hopefully we can put an elongated or
continuous object in a single frame and
here's a proof evidence okay that he
went there we put the whole uh single
thread that we have underlying our
Theory right or actually the hypothesis
uh and you see it in a single frame
okay the whole the whole thing is in one
frame it doesn't stretch to the other
frames in the movie because again the
universal movie is a concept that says
that anything with within a single frame
is
um an object a thing it has uh no motion
whatsoever
okay that's the first part but here's
another fella and he comes up with this
he says um
all liquids solids and gases are in a
rapid state of motion if you zoom in
close enough there's no such thing as a
still object in other words he's saying
that the electrons in his film are
moving okay
but see we have to distinguish the film
he's got in his hands which he doesn't
realize this uh versus the movie that
we're talking about the universal movie
says that in the frame nothing moves not
even an electron moves everything is
static everything has distance with
respect to everything else everything
only has location everything only exists
and he doesn't understand that he thinks
that oh the electrons are always moving
yeah they're moving in your film not in
God's Universal movie film okay so we
have to distinguish one from the other
and I mean she just doesn't know the
difference between a frame and a movie
yeah he thinks that uh he holds a film
in his hand he said well but the atoms
app make that uh frame of the film
they're moving the electrons are moving
in there bill yeah I know no kidding we
know that because that's not what we're
talking about we're talking about the
universal movie where we're seeing let's
all we have is cross sections of
location
distances so in any any frame in that
movie in the Universal movie we'll call
it God's movie if you want
every frame only has location
every atom in the universe every
electron everything just has distance
static distance location nothing but so
you can't say well the electrons are
moving no not in that frame that's not
the same frame that you have in your
hand a little bit of film that has made
out of atoms which and whose electrons
move around those are two different
things so I don't know if I got through
to him but I tried
okay so this is our Universal movie okay
every frame here we look at frames 1005
thousand six Thousand Seven everything
just has location within each frame
there's nothing moving in the frame
that's the entire universe there every
bit of matter nothing moves with respect
to anything else okay so that's what
we're saying is the universal movie I
owe someone out there understands what I
just said if you ever make a movie
called The Universal movies
uh that's why they call it Universal
Studios they do that yeah
okay so this is uh chopping time that's
what the universal movie is all about so
one frame is the present it's where the
past and the future meet the present the
now well it doesn't it be present though
well I could I mean we use the word
present to say it's where the passenger
meat what I mean is you could be talking
about hypothetical or something happened
in the past yeah I'm just ripping a
frame out of somewhere and it's not
necessarily the present
okay but what I'm saying is that frame
where the past and the future meet
anywhere where you cut that we'll call
it the present okay we'll just call it
the president it's just a name and we're
saying that only has locations set of
distances and existence all static
Concepts okay there's no motion right
there where God chopped it in one frame
in one frame the whole purpose of the
frame is to be able to analyze exactly
it's to be able to talk especially to
identify the objects that you're going
to use people have these uh things
running and say oh but plasma no no you
can't put Plasma in that single frame
that's the point it's a good way to to
to distinguish
where the shapes of things are at I.E
the objects are because they're not
moving you can't confuse it's motion or
it's what what do you call it ellipse
ellipses ellipses you can't confuse its
orbit there's no picture of an orbit so
it's a good way to just say if you take
a picture of it orbital for example yeah
you can't take a picture of an orbital
but you can take a picture of what is
orbiting right and so what we're doing
is uh cutting all the noise so it
doesn't bother you
okay we're trying to cut down on the
noise
okay so uh here's what we see that's
frame 1006 what do we have there we have
only distance existence and location all
three are static Concepts there's no
motion there's no orbiting there's no
plasma no time no fire no fire no time
okay only distance location and
existence there are no Concepts I mean
right I mean no sorry no Dynamic yeah
yeah you split them up into Dynamic and
static Concepts because you can have
distance in a picture but you can't have
jumping or displacement yeah see this
place is what mathematics uses because
they they measure everything and people
say well what's the length length is the
static concept isn't it yes and no if
it's qualitative it's a static concept
the length of mathematics is unrolling
the measuring tape and they tell you one
meter what is one meter that means they
unrolled a measuring tape full of little
uh tiles okay so they count tiles that's
not a static concept okay so nothing in
mathematics is static everything is in
motion when they talk about geometry and
they say look here we have a cube as
long as you talk about length width and
height qualitative no problem but as
soon as you start measuring talking
about volume for example or the sides of
of uh of a cube for example you know uh
and they're talking about meters or or
feet or whatever now they're measuring
now they're unrolling the measuring tape
no longer is it a static concept there
are no static Concepts in geometry in in
mainstream geometry because it's all
measurement and measurement is motion
and there's no static Concept in
mathematics at all every equation
it represents motion that's what an
equation is you plot one point you
change the variable put another Point
another Point another point now you know
how the deer ran that's what it is there
is no equation that has that represents
a static concept especially you know you
don't have an equation that represents I
don't know a plane or a solid or any of
those even a line uh we're talking about
the stick not about the measurement of
the stick okay so we have the
distinguishers not a number line yeah a
number line yeah okay so what what are
these people referring to they're
referring to what are known as phase
Transitions okay and you have enthalpy
there that uh what you have is
increasing heat okay and what it is is
um with the same pressure okay and all
these are essentially what you see there
phase Transitions and uh repeat that
phrase in your mind every day now phase
transition because they're not talking
about solid gas or liquid they're saying
look this is how a solid converts to
liquid if you heat it and it converts to
a gas if you heat it converts to plasma
if you heat it those are phase
transitions those are not solid liquid
and gas and so here let's take it one
step further so that you see what I'm
talking about okay let me get rid of
this in here
and uh yeah if I can heat a solid and
turn it into a liquid liquid into uh gas
what are we going to call the
intermediate steps there uh do we have a
name for those uh the saw liquid is that
what we'll call the one between solid
and liquid how about the liquid gas
what do we have in between where we had
the transition
do we have a name for all those
so we have to distinguish the transition
from the state plasma like uh any phase
is a transition not a state state is a
static concept transition uh
um what is it um phase those are all
Dynamic Concepts those involve motion
time Etc et cetera Etc so what you got
to do is figure out what what you were
gonna what you're going to call the ones
in between so you're saying plasma is a
phase right it's a phase it's a
transition that makes sense and because
you have to have first you have to have
time in motion and uh
and two frames of the film yeah
before and after because you're going to
have the atom again and then in the next
rain the atom loses an electron so
there's a transition and it's the
transition that's called plasma not the
end result because the end result again
includes atoms which have not lost their
electrons atoms that have gained back an
electron because there's a recombination
and then you have atoms that lost their
electron completely and is soup
ongoing soup is called plasma okay no
such thing as static plasma where you
can point your plasma as soon as you
freeze everything everything recombines
back again and you have gas not plastic
Okay so
okay so here it is phase is not a state
of the union state of uh Arizona none of
that okay phase a series of events
process of change those are the
definitions for phase okay phase of
matter one of the distinct forms in
which matter can exist
absolutely not because phase and exist
are contradictory terms what does exist
physical presence no uh Motion in any of
those two words physical requires an
object again no uh a thing no motion
involved in the definition of thing and
location again no motion involved in
location so a phase of whatever is not
exist not a synonym of exist you can't
Define it in terms of the word exist
exist as a static concept and the
definition of exist contains no
provision for motion you do not need
time for example to Define existence
when I say this exists
are you saying this exists in time over
time over over many frames of the
universal movie no we're saying it
exists means it has it's an object it
has location so it's a static concept
that falls in a single frame of the
universal movie
okay so here we have the rundown this is
location set of distances
and state is a synonym of location
condition at a specific location that's
what state is what is motion in contrast
more than one location okay you need two
uh at least two like in the example
below you see an atom where the little
electron orbiting at one place and in
the next round your the electron is
another place okay so you need two
frames of the film to show that an
electron moved
otherwise you have location just uh the
um
electron at a given distance from its
nucleus actually that's a good question
but if you zoom in enough to atoms can
you even tell what state they're in no
they could never they can't even like
add a man you mean like if I had a man
yeah if you go in and you see each ball
for example again okay and I take that I
use that example I said take Adam man
he's small enough right he's got his
camera right he goes down there takes a
picture whatever he takes let's assume
the elect of the atom is what Quantum
says you know a little bead that goes
around the nucleus fine no problem he
takes a snapshot of that could take it
also of the cloud the model etc etc
whatever he takes a picture he takes a
picture now he brings it back that
picture forget about the electrons that
are moving within the atoms in the
picture we're talking about the picture
okay that one is a still image yeah so
whatever you got there the electrons on
this side are on that side of the
nucleus yeah but that one period where
can you tell that it's a solid gas or a
fluid
I think not
well I mean if you take a picture of two
atoms next to each other okay
you there's no way of knowing let's say
they're both hydrogen atoms right yeah
if you get if you zoom in close enough
you can't tell if they're uh fluid if
they're uh uh if they're moving gas no
you can't tell what state they are well
yeah you can because all you have is
distance in the photograph yeah and I I
zoom in zoom in zoom in as far as you
want at some point you're just going to
get distance yeah because the other atom
is going to be over there you can't tell
what state it's in but I mean distance
is a static concept and if in in your
picture conceptually right in your
picture uh they have a specified
distance separation not not measuring
but uh yeah yeah they're not they're not
the same right yeah but you can't tell
you have a static image yeah but you
don't can't tell what state they are the
state meeting what state is uh
if it's a gas if it's a solid well it's
either of those I'll give you a better
example than that I take a snapshot of
milk on the floor yeah and I show it to
the ET he doesn't know what milk it is
he says that's a solid because it's it's
standing still right and so I took a
picture of something which is a liquid
but because I took a picture I kind of
solidified it in a way that it's unless
you have prior knowledge of what's in
the picture you can't tell if it's a
little bit or not what we do is we just
say uh you know I don't need to have
milk running down the hill I see a
puddle of milk on the floor even if I
take a snapshot of it or whatever
because I mean I show it to someone yeah
and we say what is that that's a liquid
yeah that's all we say psych it's frozen
it's frozen melts but it just looks the
same yeah it could be frozen it could be
a solid but you know that's why we have
these categories for what we're pointing
at right okay uh exist object plus
location so state is what a condition of
existence that's what it is and there
you can see exist nothing moving in that
single frame on the other hand time is
not the same thing as existence you need
at least uh two locations more than one
at least and
um
time like motion requires at least two
frames okay
so um neither uh
um what is it neither
um time nor motion uh are synonyms of
state they're synonyms of phase and vice
versa state is neither motion or time
it's location and uh distance and
existence
so that's essentially it and here's the
final picture
summary I guess you could say Okay
location set of distances state is a
condition at a specific location that's
what a state is what is a phase a
process of change okay for example ice
turning into water okay that that could
be a phase okay you can say it's phasing
yes
and what are you going to call the
intermediate transition condition we
have no name for that we say well ice
turned into water the the
objectification of the concepts is
really weird when people point to Fire
Point to Shadow or point to plasma these
things really muddy the water don't they
is that why you're so adamant about that
I'm adamant because people confuse
objects with objects in motion process
that's essentially it I always give the
example of uh kangaroo versus a jumping
kangaroo plasma is a jumping kangaroo
ether is a jumping kangaroo okay does
light fall into that seam because no
because as the Rope is it light light is
the torquing of the Rope
both that's the issue because we use the
word light yeah but no no no I'm saying
the following I'm saying light is used
for both for the entity and the motion
of the entity because we've never
separated in other words light but we've
always you talked about it in terms of
energy energies that can Dynamic
Concepts so we say light is the signal
yeah but but nobody ever said well what
is the object that mediates light and
yeah and even then they say it's a bunch
of particles that are flowing they never
show one particle one Photon and say
this is a photon and I'm in a nest uh
two hours I'm gonna explain how it moves
now they never point to one they just
say light is Flowing particles they
already go to the to the movie uh and
they jump uh or they skip you know that
first frame of the movie where you point
to the object but technically light is a
process the torquing of the Rope Rope is
that which mediates light it doesn't
light itself it's both it's gravity it's
both I mean no gravity is also a
relationship between it's both because
we've never qualified it in terms of
what is the object that is uh yeah
just easier to cut it like why say both
because it's not the Rope I like to say
both because I like to start always my
films at frame number one and people
always start uh with strips with with a
whole strip of film and I don't want
they already say it's a flowing
particles no no I don't want that I want
to show
how did the movie start
okay so that's the issue okay uh we had
our scientific uh science critic and
um he I guess he made a new uh video uh
talking about
um what was it um predictions so I think
he's become an astrologer and I think
it's good for him because I don't think
he was good as a scientist so he's
probably going to do better with
astrology if he's going to be talking
about predictions but I'm not going to
address that today uh in fact I won't
address him in this uh instance because
something else came up and I think I
need to address it Christmas
not quite here we have this fellow and
he says the following he was a little
upset he says I'm not sure who you're
trying to refute but these are not the
words of ain't Rand Ein Rand someone
call her okay some people call it please
provide a source of the material that
you are trying to attribute to in Rand
and that's what he was criticizing the
fact that I took all these
um quotations from her okay and he
didn't like a lot of these he said no
that's not what she said and so we have
to look at what did she say I mean did
she say all these things where did I get
all this stuff did I get out of my at
the top of my head uh you know where did
I get it from and so the first thing we
need to show is the books that she wrote
and these are the three main books where
all these Quotes come from okay
basically Atlas Shrug which was her
first novel slash where she gave her
philosophy Etc whatever you want to call
what she gave her recommendations
and um this is where I got all those
quotes Okay because fortunately someone
did the work for me already I have no
reason to doubt them and you'll see why
okay and this is lexicon.com in Rand
lexicon right uh the introductions by
Leonard uh uh piekoff he was like her
right-hand man and this site was created
by Harry Binswanger who is still a board
member of the Ayn Rand Institute and he
creates this glossary and you'll see
under letter E the two words that I'm
interested in which are entity and
existence
so I did not invent these definitions I
did not invent uh you know the sources
and not only that uh Mr Binswanger does
one good thing and he shows where he got
each one of those definitions from from
which book so you don't have to take my
word just go there to that side it's uh
you could say an authoritative site
um they go in there and tell you exactly
what quotes he made and from what book
it came from and then you have
commentaries also by Mr ventranger yeah
I've heard of Atlee shrug but I don't
know I never read it okay and uh so this
is the problem with it the problem is
that no one has defined the word
philosophy in the last 10 000 years and
you see these different definitions
the study of the fundamental nature of
knowledge reality and existence
especially when considered as an
academic discipline
the study of the basic ideas about
knowledge truth right and wrong religion
and the nature and meaning of life
the rational abstract and methodical
consideration of reality as a whole or a
fundamental dimensions of human
existence and experience this philosophy
right yeah all these are the
systematized study of general and
fundamental questions such as those
about existence reason knowledge values
mind and language and then I like the
last one which is the Stanford
encyclopedia philosophy it does not have
a definition here you have they're going
to talk about philosophy this is what
they do and they don't Define the word
philosophy they're not big on
definitions are they yeah so all these
you know they they just vaguely State oh
your philosophy is this this and that
and what you'll find really is that no
one has really defined it in fact uh
when you go I think the Wikipedia says
some along those lines that no one
really has defined philosophy very well
and they include in ontology they
include knowledge they include
recommendations politics religion a
little bit of everything it's like
you're everybody's on a philosophy well
it's kind of because as everyone means a
little bit something different like we
all have the same ballpark but if you
put it if as soon as you Cookie Cutter
it people are like ah not but what I
consider to be philosophy has things
that aren't in your cookie cutter and
you know why that's the problem because
no one defined the word philosophy if
you define the word philosophy very
strictly a better way of saying
everything we haven't agreed no no it's
not a question no agreeance a question
of Defending Your definitions showing
that you can use it consistently that's
the way we do it in science
and that's what I'm gonna do here okay
and uh so here we have uh some of the
subfields by Wikipedia because of that
you know they have all these metaphysics
epistemology ethics logic I mean is
metaphysics the same thing as logic is
ethics the same thing as epistemology
it's like you know they put they covered
all the bases like saying philosophy is
everything is the whole it's all four
bases in in the game it's not just first
base or second it's all four of them
that's what they did essentially and so
anyone's a useless word so yeah in a way
it becomes a useless word because oh I
do ethics oh I'm and I'm a philosopher
the other guy says oh but I do knowledge
and I'm a philosopher and it's like we
don't talk to each other because I'm I'm
a different kind of philosopher yeah you
know are we in philosophy or not to
begin with you know the words has lost
his meaning and so just to clarify here
this is Benji Franklin again he created
the American philosophical Society just
so people don't get confused it has
nothing to do with philosophy Mr
Franklin even said that it um it has to
do with in those days they called
philosophy science
uh like uh Newton called his uh treaties
uh philosophical blah blah blah they
called it um what is a natural
philosophy okay so uh just in case uh
the American philosophical Society has
nothing to do with philosophy it's got
to do with uh the study of what they did
in the those days which was known as
natural philosophy which today is called
science okay which is the line of Newton
not the line of philosophers such as
Aristotle and so on not not holy from
there okay so uh here we have it these
were not philosophers uh Plato Aristotle
St Thomas David Hume
Wittgenstein uh sortner none of these
guys were philosophers because what they
did were recommendations on how to live
that's what they did their clerics yeah
and uh recommendations is known as a
religious person it's a person who goes
out there and says look this is how you
should behave in society before else
this is what's going to happen to you
and this is the way government should be
run because otherwise you know and so
and that's what in Rand did she did a
lot of that and she tried to justify it
by saying oh I'm gonna Define some of
the key terms empathy meaning object
thing and existence and she failed
miserably at both as I showed this
fellow okay because uh her definitions
are no different than David Humes and
Emmanuel Kant uh they had the same
definitions in other words uh I
mentioned this a couple times already
where especially Hume uh said there's no
he could see no difference between the
word object and the word exist because
he says what does exist add to the word
object and can't said exactly the same
thing 50 years later in his readings and
so the issue is yeah there is a
difference object is that which has
shape and existence adds location to it
they are not synonyms and uh good old uh
Enron she did not discover that and so
she doesn't get a cigar I don't think
she likes cigars anyway so yeah yeah
that's good hard to smoke yeah and so uh
here's my the philosophical definition
of philosophy okay this is the one they
should put at the uh Stanford
Encyclopedia of what philosophy science
is divided into parts and science does
what rational explanations physics deals
with rational explanations of phenomena
looks at causes and mechanisms and the
bread and butter is object the object
what does philosophy do well philosophy
is rational explanations because it's
part of science a branch of science of
what of behaviors
and it looks at reasons and purposes and
the bread and butter is the concept okay
philosophy rational explanations of
behaviors I guess another good clean way
to distinguish those is how and why
right
uh yeah
we have to be careful with the words how
especially with word how because
sometimes you say how did that have how
did this happen you know we let go of
the magic wand Bill Gates Magic One how
did that happen some people say Well it
happened at uh 9.8 meters per second
okay yeah and so the word how can be
treated that's how fast I just mean how
I don't mean how fast or how much
let's see this is the issue the issue is
how is a little misleading oh so is why
and what no no no but why also is
misleading because people confuse
philosophy with uh physics physics
answers uh when when you ask why they
look at the mechanism the causes whereas
when you look at philosophy the why has
to do with reasons and purposes why did
you do that why did God create the
universe and so people think that's a
question of physics when it's not it has
to do with what was going through God's
mind we're talking about uh philosophy
why he did something but people
introduced that into physics saying why
is the universe here meaning why did God
create the universe the answer is always
the same because God had a headache
that's why that's what I thought we
didn't do philosophy
leave that to the philosophers okay
we'll go through some of the questions
then open up the floor for questions if
there are any uh here's the first one
follow says your hypothesis tells us
that light should bend
this invalidates your hypothesis
entirely doesn't it yeah I guess it does
I had pointed this out earlier but you
but you paid no heed you only addressed
comments of people who are ignorant
about your theory people who Point flaws
in your theory go unaddressed by you
don't they so fellas uh because you
asked the question he thinks you're
ignorant uh because uh I only answer
your questions and left this out uh the
first thing I want to say on that is
that I try to answer all questions if I
don't answer one of your questions maybe
I didn't see it maybe I didn't think it
was important or relevant or whatever
and ask it again no problem uh I'll see
it at some point it's not that I you
know select uh people I select the
questions or the comments I post lots of
questions of people really looking for
good questions right in fact I'm looking
for people who oppose me I do try to
something you haven't thought of before
uh what or or people who have questions
where they criticize and those are the
ones I'm going to address especially
those people so I have no problem with
people coming here and throwing mud in
my eyes no problem whatsoever you can
cuss my mother here that's uh not my
grandmother
okay but uh as far as this gun is
concerned I don't know where he got this
uh light uh rope bending that the Rope
should bend because they come out of the
Sun or whatever light bends because it
goes from like rope to rope and then off
to the side but that's not I don't I
don't know that's the Rope bending but
yeah he thinks the Rope is bending like
this you know and I don't know where he
got most Bend
when they do their thing in magnetism
they do Bend but ropes never Bend
they're always they're always uh pulled
taut you know tight uh they're Adam
against Adam they're always under
tension so and and attention is governed
by tiny little C uh 300 000 kilometers
per second is the speed of light meaning
the speed of torque meaning it's a
constant why because it's a tension
it's the only way that you can explain
tension uh and why the speed of light is
constant okay there can't be a flow so
where you got the idea that the Rope
should bend and that's why maybe you
should have pointed to like uh I have no
idea what he meant yeah but see these
guys just throw it out there and then
run away well his heart I mean and he
says I didn't answer his question that's
the thing I've edited your books enough
to know to know that when you think you
know what you're talking about the other
person doesn't yeah and I found this
with uh especially with a universal
movie I thought I thought this was
kindergarten stuff that we did not need
to clarify anything more about the
universal movie that a frame has no
motion and these people don't understand
that simple thing they're saying no but
the electrons are moving within the film
here let me show you the film that I
have at home
and that's not the film we're talking
about you know he doesn't realize that
okay another fellow says lightning is
plasma lightning it has shape what are
you calling that which has shaped he's
got you there yeah lightning does not
have shape because shape is a static
concept and you can see that uh that
thing uh is not static it's moving
lightning is what a naturally occurring
occurring okay
electrostatic discharge discharge this
church has Motion in it okay it's
discharge uh static okay it depends on
what next charge you're talking about
doing it that discharge come out of my
nose and you can take a picture of it
yeah
after the fact otherwise it's not this
yet when it comes out it's called snot
uh the instantaneous release of energy
okay but instantaneous means what uh if
it's release it can't be instantaneous
and that's the problem people use these
words of ordinary speech especially the
mathematicians and they say
instantaneous readies no such monster
release takes
um motion two frames of the film
instantaneous should be a single frame
of the film but what happens is when
they say instantaneous they mean
extremely fast and that's I don't care
how fast you want to make it it's going
to take two uh you have a comparison and
that's why we have to create these
Concepts such as the universal movie so
that we do not get away with murder and
say instantaneous release yeah people
are not aware of these uh contradictions
it's very hard they're all
um what do you call oxymorons but that's
the thing
I think humans in general are just so
I guess prone to
I don't want to say poetry but using
language Loosely we're not robots
yeah you're bringing robotism into human
language which is just unnatural that's
the thing that's why it's so difficult
for everyone to keep track but but you
made a point once you said when you
program to look for those of you who are
programmers out there you program
something the machine is going to follow
your programming if you're programming
it wrong or you try to cheat
and say well it's an object but it's an
object in motion you know like plasma
and you cheat it because if it's an
object it's got to be you got to show it
standing still and when you show it
standing still the computer says it
doesn't compute you got a problem you
design something wrong okay but let's
continue with this fellow he says
Lightning Electric spark discharge you
can see all these words show uh motion
in fact you see the film there on the
upper right it shows uh electricity
that's what it shows that's what
lightning is in the atmosphere occurring
within between a cloud and the ground
to emit a flash again emit flash or
flashes of lightning okay so everywhere
you see
um nothing ecstatic I mean a flash is
already a a fire a word because Flash
you need a before and after a knot right
and a bright so lightning does not have
shape shape is a static concept and if
you take a snapshot of lightning
we don't have lightning we have we have
an object there something we don't we
can't recognize we don't know what to
call it you might want to call it
lightning but lightning you got to use
the word from the dictionary and
lightning says it's a process
so you can't call that lightning you
just call it something whatever that is
all the atoms it's it's the same thing
as plasma when you take a snapshot of
plasma we don't have a name for that and
we don't have a name for taking a
snapshot of lightning because whenever
you took a picture of is no longer
lightning lightning is something in
motion plasma is something in motion you
need you need a film to talk about
either one
okay another fellow here he says that uh
rope is a process you define your thread
ropes as a process
where the I mean are these people
watching the same thing where are they
getting this nonsense again I think they
don't differentiate between the rope and
its motions
I have no idea maybe they're watching
something else and they're confusing
with us I don't know it's hard to get
all this stuff aligned yeah because they
get it so bad that they say rope is a
process what do you mean here here's a
rope okay this is a rope
is that a process
Jesus go to go to the um go to the uh
the hardware store and ask for a process
and see if they give you a rope ask for
a rope see if they gave you a process
foreign
I don't know
okay another found out what mechanism
was present at the beginning of the
universe to create your thread ropes you
like that face don't you always do well
I gotta put those faces in there because
these people have to be really kidding
me I mean creating a rope I thought we
made it clear that matter was never
created that there was no origin to the
unit the universe which is a concept
really but to matter matter did not have
a beginning you cannot have a beginning
to matter because having a beginning
means that you're going to turn space
nothing that which has no length width
or height no shape nothing and you're
going to turn that into something
suddenly it acquires length width and
heightened turns into a ball or whatever
explain the process with or without God
I'll even let you introduce God show me
the process tell me give me the spec I
want to know how it's made from zero
from nothing to turn into well zero to
one would be enough well that'd be math
but
this is the issue for frame zero you
cannot you cannot even conceptualize
such a mechanism not even poor old God
can imagine that he says what do these
people think I am a magician
[Applause]
how can I create something from nothing
not even I know how to do that says God
you know okay he's not that smart
okay we fellow says Faraday to deduced
at the action at a distance between the
compass and the inductive device was
caused by something okay what was it
Faraday said that ether was a spatial
medium
said that ether is an ultra rare feat
rarified rarified gas a condition of of
the matter a state of matter yeah again
they use State because uh Tesla was not
smart enough to know the difference
between a state and a phase a
pre-hydrogen atoms
a sort of atmosphere that permeates
everything Etc bill says ropes connect
everything we could deduce that the
ether is a state of matter
or a pre-state of matter that has not
yet structured itself as such
I mean that is essentially what people
say the ether is right pre-matter so
from which matter it emerges
a soup from where matter emerges you
mean for The Ether yeah but the issue
with the ether you have to first Define
what ether is and the problem there is
that ether is a forest it's not a tree
yeah that's the problem and a forest is
not an object a tree is an object a
forest is not the way they've always
conceptualized The Ether ever since the
days of the Greeks uh even before them
because the ether existed or it was
around still even before the Greeks but
the Greece gave it the name that we use
it today The Ether right which is uh
some kind of air that's what ether meant
and today we use that same notion and
the notion is that we have all these
little particles out there and that they
uh underlie all phenomena in other words
it's the motion of those particles that
is a wave and the wave is like it always
comes down to particles so that's why I
Define ether for all those who want to
break their heads ether is a bunch of
particles that's what ether is a bunch
of particles is not an object now people
say Bill you got it wrong that's not
what the ether is good tell me what the
ether is don't tell me what it ain't
don't tell me that I'm wrong that that's
not what the ether is tell me what the
ether is and hopefully you don't Define
it hopefully you show me a picture and
say that's ether like when I point to a
table or a chair or a rock and I say
that's a rock
because otherwise you can't use this in
an object if you're going to define the
word ether you don't have an object it's
Concepts which we Define objects we
point to a name
okay so if you can't point a name to The
Ether
uh it's a concept you can't use it to
say well The Ether vibrates and that's
what light is no you can't do that it's
irrational okay
and the final issue here
comment someone said the normal
visualization of space-time is somewhat
obsolete some time ago I found this
video that believe it or not made me
visualize in my mind the space-time
really and so he's saying you know this
notion that we have that
um space times this flat
um uh fishnet and that you pull it down
with fish
and uh he's saying that two-dimensional
notion turns into three-dimensional is
not really the proper way to look at
space time space time has to be looked
at according to these people in fact I
went to see that video and I I already
had seen it many times uh you can see
that the one on the bottom it sucks
um
space time to the Center of the Earth
everything falls to the center
the problem with that is that you know
um it looks like a bunch of ropes
no no but even then it's it's wrong I
mean it's not wrong because if
everything pulls inwards okay uh we've
got a problem first because space time
is a concept
I mean so you cannot illustrate time so
these people put line these lines these
little lines there let's call them ropes
[Music]
that's basically what they drew
what these people are saying is you know
everything gets pulled in okay and we
have no problem with that but the
problem is that they're using a concept
to do that they're saying it's time
and you can't say that time pulls on
anything you know and that's what
they're saying essentially there well
not to so whether whether you use the 2D
or the 3D we'll call the bottom one 3D
whether you use either one of those
um
uh illustrations those films to those
mechanisms to explain gravity it's
irrational it's irrational because what
you're saying is time is pulling
something downwards and that is
irrational okay not only that where does
all the where does it all go oh the
slack yeah
yeah where's he coming from yeah yeah
in in the case that's why it's not a
rope either because you can see that's
being stretched yeah that's not what
we're saying we're not saying the ropes
are stretched okay they're not made of
rubber uh a rope is always taught okay
between two atoms it's under tension
that tension is governed by the tiny
letter C and uh all we have is uh atoms
which approach other atoms and uh
because they form part of objects as
they get closer the ropes fan out
they're always straight they're always
pulled tight but they fan out and that's
what tells you uh Newton's distance law
that you know the inverse square of the
distance you could say the the angles
of all the ropes pretty bad the amount
of angle I guess the amount of angle I
look at it in a different uh way and
that is that they are not superimposed
ropes are on the same axis but suddenly
as one object approaches another
obviously they're out of alignment
they're no longer on the same axis and
now you have what I call independent or
effective ropes okay so you have more
and more effective or independent ropes
rather than on the same axis and you can
see that when two objects are very far
away from each other all the ropes
should you know come into a single
coaxial so it turns into a tube and
that's why gravity is weak at Great
distances
any questions there yeah actually okay
got a couple
here
uh grab that guy who said I don't answer
his question and you find him in there
first one was something about
are you going to acknowledge the
existence of supercritical fluids
supercritical fluids like what
what do you mean Super critical fluids I
think I think that's a fluid that's
about to turn into a different uh state
but I'm not I'm not sure uh there were
super fluids but they're not super
critical fluid super fluids is something
else I don't know if he's referring to
that I don't know what a super critical
never heard of that uh do gravity and
light travel at the same speed we had a
lot of people answering them saying
neither of them travel
first of all yeah neither of them travel
that's true uh I mean you could say what
travels really is the signal and what
we're seeing is not even the signal what
it is is you measure something right
like light in the case of light right
you measure something here at origin and
the other guy has a mirror or whatever
at the other side and he measures it
over there like and we have a special
case which is the uh lunar Ranger
ranging experiment which is a mirror put
on the moon and a uh shine a laser
against it okay so um they can measure
the the round trip of light and so we
measure and we say Okay light travel but
what is it that travel was there
something traveling well if if you
torque a rope right if you talk a rope
nothing really traveled in the sense
that there there's nothing traveling
from one hand from one of my hands to
the other I gotta put your head away
nothing traveled from one hand to the
other the Rope is still there what
traveled is you could say travel is this
disturbance this signal which is not a
thing in itself the bumps it's like the
wave wave is not a thing but suddenly
this wave Distortion is disturbance
appears at the other end why because I
think tort in situ yeah so there is no
traveling August say it traveled in the
sense that that is a type of travel they
I like the better a better word is
propagate because propagate is not a
travel it's like something just a
disturbance that moves I guess you can
use the word propagate
with a lot of uh you know quotations
there you can use it for uh Concepts
like signals like waves you can say look
the signal propagates but the Rope only
Twisted in situated as far as there's a
rope is concerned nothing travel you
think it traveled because you measure it
origin and at uh you know at the
Destiny you know at the destination yeah
destination so you have uh source and uh
Target and yeah uh because of that we
think something is traveling I think we
got someone confused about magnetism
does magnetism not atoms does magnesium
not consist of atoms
well magnetism does not consist of
electrons or atoms has nothing to do
with electrons like a lot of people
think they think it's a current of some
kind going from one to the other that we
can't see no this has nothing to do with
current or with atoms what we have in
here are threads and the threads are
going like this you know unless you do
it this way uh if they go in the same
direction when one comes down
you know going like this the other one
no hits it you did it wrong
yeah you gotta do if they go like this
when one comes up the other one comes
down and they pull that's pulling if
they both clash they hit each other and
go away that's what a magnet is doing
according to us according to the site
what is doing the what is doing the
swinging the threads that form the rope
and the atoms they swing around the
atoms and around the ropes
actually that's a good question is there
gravity in the center of the earth I
mean obviously gravity but is there I
guess measurable gravity like if you go
to the Center of the Earth would you be
pulled apart but you would think that if
you just considered the Earth because
obviously there is gravity in the center
of the Earth where with respect to
Jupiter yeah we're not counting that
okay so we can say that the center of
the earth is a point Mass that's the way
they talk about it is let's not use
those words
that has all the mass of the Earth all
the weight of the Earth in that little
point but if you hollowed that's a
mathematical concept okay I guess this
is this is the thought experiment if you
holla out let's say a small room in the
center of the earth so there's no iron
and I just and you just teleported me
there I just appeared there would I go
up down be pulled apart get crushed down
and the answer is very very simple
you're going to be pulled by every atom
on Earth outwards yeah so you're gonna
be pulled apart kind of you know if
you're strong if you're strong enough
you know you won't be like uh quartered
as they did in the days of the British
where they take four horses and rip the
guy apart uh that's the way you would be
using someone from everywhere someone
would pop like a balloon no not
necessarily I mean I don't know what
would happen there but you would be
pulled by every atom on uh on Earth
outwards
so uh you know every atom in your body
would be pulled outward because
everything is but remember not only is
this atom being pulled in this direction
that same atom is pulled in opposite
direction as well so every atom in your
body is pulled in every direction
that makes sense actually I don't think
you'd be ripped apart but you would
stand still a super a super ass super
critical fluid is both gas and liquid
yeah but I mean they make all these uh
unnecessary categories that's the issue
there's only three categories they don't
need three states well they're necessary
because if you're going to talk about
super cooled or whatever you're talking
about cooling heating you're talking
about temperature you know motion
pressure possibly you're talking about
motion so they they mix these super cool
because they're talking not about states
of matter they're talking about phases
of matter they're talking about the
process not about the end the end result
that's the issue
would it be zero gravity in the center
of the Earth
I would say uh well I can't tell you we
call it zero gravity I'm saying you're
gonna be pulled by every atom would you
be floating yes I don't know weird yeah
all I can tell you all I can tell you is
every the the at least according to this
site every atom in your body is pulled
in every single Direction even from
every atom in the universe by the way
right now I'm being pulled by it yeah
but in the center of the earth I guess
the the rather close they're Closer by
that's the relevant gravity would be
canceled out so you'd be floating yeah
yeah
but yeah I'm saying that you would be in
the center and you'd be pulled in every
direction I think you would be standing
still and then you would suffer no
gravity because you are the center of
gravity everything pulls towards you're
the center of the universe standing
still in the wrong way you wouldn't be
standing you'd be floating
well there's well like if you're
crunched in it depends on how how much
room yeah I mean if you were in a room
in the center of the earth you'd just be
floating there anything yeah it's hard
to make it with a human because a human
is not a little point it's better to do
with a little ball made of a single
piece then you could talk about the
center of the universe but when you say
what would happen to me well you'd
probably I don't know be pulled in One
Direction More than another and another
because you are not a perfectly
symmetric object like a ball
but close enough okay with that we'll
see you next Sunday and merry Christmas
happy New Years Happy New Year for next
I'll see you next year
the sun went around the earth one more
time
no one is two years older everyone is
one year old right yep there's no
relativity we'll see you next time